do you quote finnegan's wake uh mad
props for that james joyce book i took a
class in james joyce in college
i think i read parts of finning and way
i might have been on drugs of some kind
or i um i somehow got an a in that class
which probably refers to some kind of
curve where nobody understood anything
the only thing i understood and really
enjoyed is his short stories the dead
and then ulysses i kind of uh i think
read a few cliff notes that kind of got
to the point and finnegan's awake was
just a hopeless person i it's a you
for people who haven't looked at it
maybe you can
elucidate to me better but
i felt like i was reading things
words and the words made sense
like standing next to each other
but when you
kind of read for a while
you realize you didn't actually
understand anything that was said right
but did you have a feeling though that's
one that's one thing i found interesting
about finnegan's week i i never fully
understood it but the words caused
feelings in me which i found fascinating
and and sometimes i i couldn't predict
it from the the semantic you know black
and white context of what i was seeing
in front of me on the page but the
rhythm or the melody would make me feel
certain ways and that's that was what i
always was intrigued by with joyce of
course that was his
he he existed on a spectrum too and he
wrote as you say you know more
accessible uh works you know i learned a
lot about irish history from you know
portrait of the artist as a young man
and there was just
he could be as objective as he wanted to
be but then when he let himself
loose
he was in this realm where the words had
their own
purpose separate from from
you know semantic meaning from their
their dry uh you know dictionary
definition you know there's a funny
story that was told
doesn't matter if it's true or not but
they they said that uh james joyce when
he was young when he was in his teen
years would go around
instead of ireland drinking and so on
and telling everybody that he's going to
be one of if not the greatest writers of
the 20th century
and uh he turned out to be that
so the that i always think about that
little story that somebody told me
because i have a lot of people come up
to me including myself i'm a bit of a
dreamer i and
you know you get into certain moods
where you say i'm going to be the
greatest
anything ever you you get like people
tell you this uh young especially young
people
and it kind of
it makes me feel all kinds of ways but
that story reminds me that
like you just might be
one of the greatest
writers of the 21st century for example
if somebody were to tell me that and
like don't
just don't immediately disregard that
because one of the people that say that
that's almost like a pre-condition
that's like a requirement just to
believe in yourself maybe it's not a
full requirement but it's it's an
interesting story
i think when someone tells you that then
it creates uh
you one sees an opportunity and then it
would be a tragedy if the opportunity
weren't captured right so then that
creates a um some some impetus uh some
motivation to do something
something good i think the mind it's
like uh
you know i guess that's what like books
like the or books or whatever i don't
even know if it's a book the secret
plugs into uh they kind of make a whole
industry out of it but there is
something about
the mind believing something making it a
reality it is just time and time again
with steve jobs like
your belief in yourself your belief in
an idea
sort of embracing the me versus the
world
embracing the madness of this idea and
making it a life pursuit
somehow morse reality around for some
tiny fraction of the population for
everybody else you descend into uh
you know all the beautiful ways that
failure
materializes in our lifetime
you know you mentioned love earlier i
mean that's that's a great example of
how belief in something makes it real
right it's it's not reasonable
on the face of it but because you
believe it's reasonable then it actually
does become reasonable and then it is
real and so that's a that's a good
example that doesn't happen i'm also in
a bioengineering department we don't
imagine that a bridge is soundly built
and then it is soundly built that's
something that it doesn't come up in too
many realms of human existence but love
is one of them and and these the ability
to
to have a fixed idea and to say it's
true and then it is true
a bridge is a kind of manifestation of
love so maybe it does work a little bit
but you know it can break down like
chernobyl did you can't just say it's
safe you have to also prove it safe
uh but on finnegan's wake
i think maybe correct me if i'm wrong
you're using kind of finnegan's wake to
give one perspective on what madness is
of what's going on in the mind how much
of that is
uh that we're simply unable
to communicate with the person on the
other side
of of their mind like there's almost
like a
a little person inside the brain
and they have some circuitry that's used
to communicate emotion communicate ideas
to the outside world and there's
something about that circuitry that
makes it difficult to communicate with a
little person on the other side so if
you look at what shows up in
schizophrenia with many cases the the
what we call thought disorders what we
call
uh the
the individual speech symptoms of
schizophrenia
finnegan's wake is is loaded with them
and it's just full of them we we talk
about uh
clang associations in schizophrenia
where the word that is said is
echoes in some way the previous word and
it's we call that a clang association
because there's no other reason than the
similarity of the sound like a like a
clang of a
of a garage door being hit and it has a
and sometimes it's not even a word and
we call that a neologism a new word
being created and of course finnegan's
wake is full of that and then we we also
in schizophrenia where there's what we
call loose associations or tangential
thought processes of course full of that
where things just go off in directions
that are not linear or logical
and
you can't read finnegan's wake i think
without um
certainly a psychiatrist you can't read
it without thinking about schizophrenia
and then when we look at
the families of people with
schizophrenia and joyce was no exception
there very often are people within the
family who are on the spectrum some have
it
some are
able to see it from a distance from a
safe distance
there's an association between
schizophrenia and what we call
schizotypal personality disorder where
people are not quite in this
severe state of schizophrenia but have
some magical thinking have some unusual
thought patterns very often those are
family members of people with
schizophrenia so this points to this
again to this idea that that there is a
range even along
this very severe
very genetic biological illness that
human beings dwell on different spots
along that spectrum i should mention
that we have my friend sergey pulling up
stuff young surgery or old sergey i
don't know what to call you but
uh there's drafts of pigeons quake yeah
i actually saw pictures of this from um
i think it was on instagram or something
these are early giraffes of finnegan's
way and it's so beautiful to see for
people were just listening there's just
random paragraphs and writing all over
the page with stuff crossed out and
it's great to see that joyce himself was
thinking in this kind of way as
um as you're putting it together how
much do you think he was thinking about
schizophrenia this schizophrenic mind i
think a lot i think you know it's it's
known that his his daughter suffered
from from schizophrenia and uh
this is what's depicted here on the page
is something that i'm sure
he either felt himself and some some
level was able to access this
non-linearity of of processing
or had seen enough in family
uh that he he knew what it was and was
able to to reflect it down in black and
white on the paper so it was what he was
able to do is was quite authentic in
that sense
of course
i don't want to pigeonhole him he was
doing much more than that it was much
more than than
talking about altered human
thought processes and thought disorders
but that was an aspect that he was
so good at representing that it had to
be intentional to some extent
you